i'm so proud to uh um
say that this man is an emmy
award-winning
broadcaster and his work on cbs sports
on the nfl today as well as of course
good morning football
merits him being the best studio analyst
for uh 2020. he is nate burleson here on
the rich eisen show how are you nate
i'm good my brother i appreciate that
introduction still sounds
surreal every time uh every time i hear
that so
um thank you though of course now that i
have you i appreciate you man
one of the first people that i met when
i went to the nfl network back in 2003
for the first time um it was you and
you've been in my corner ever since so i
appreciate our friendship
well nate that's part of the reason why
i want to you know have you on and talk
about this because
you know um you were you came on when
you were playing were you with the
the lions the vikings what were you on
who were you with
you know i was i was with the vikings
right okay 2003 yeah
right and you just decided you know and
we were we were reaching out to
um nfl players uh with a
a voice a personality with smarts
and with the desire to do the job
and and invite them into our our
studio as much as possible and i
remember you were
you were up to the task and having fun
and standing out and uh if i told you
that day you were gonna be an emmy award
winner one day what would you have told
me
nate burleson i would have told you you
were lying because i didn't think i was
going into tv
at all once i got done playing you know
i was thankful that
you know i made decent money and i took
care of it
proper investment so going into tv was
something i did because
i really enjoyed speech communications
in college so i knew that i would be
using my voice
in some form or fashion a lot of guys
going to coaching
maybe motivational speaking but once i
went to the nfl network
back in 2003 i realized that it was
unique in the sense that
not only were the hosts different than
every other network
but the players were able to come in and
and not be placed in a box
we all had a chance if we wanted to to
work at the craft of being on tv but two
most importantly
show our personality and over the years
you know i've been able to take pieces
of all the individuals
that i've seen um sit at those tables
and obviously you being
one of the main guys so you know i look
at life like i used to look at football
there's certain people that you can sit
back and watch from a distance
um and if you're blessed enough they'll
drop some gems on you
and a lot of people at the nfl network
helped me get to where i am right now
well and it's not just that too nate and
then
we'll we'll move on um and talk some
football but
you know you you take a look at the
television landscape
certainly in in the nfl for sure
i think it's true of of basketball as
well you've got to have like a gold
jacket or a bust
to to break through to just get started
and that is not what you have in your
football resume but
did you run into any of those roadblocks
at all
that you as you're building your brand
and building your
your career did that ever hit you at all
for sure yeah you know once i left the
game
i was told if you have a ring or a gold
jacket
you'll have a better opportunity to find
a seat
at any network and then it's from there
you have to put in the work to keep it
now i knew
when i left the game i didn't have
either you know 11 year career
respected by my peers fine but i'm not
going to
walk into a network and get the same
type of response
that a deionized sanders and michael
lever marshall faulk is going to get
so what did i do early on in my career
as an
analyst and a broadcaster i tried to do
as much as i can
i i paid attention to what the host was
doing i tried to read teleprompter
while they were reading it i was focused
on all the little things
so i didn't look like your typical
athlete talking about the sport
and i did everything from digital to
pre-game post game
i did half times when somebody couldn't
show up i filled in
and i think one of the biggest things i
did it's a very small thing but one of
my mentors he was like look
i know you're a ball player and a wide
receiver at that
you love to stand out you're a diva but
chill out with the loud suits bro
like you're like you're like steve
harvey in the uh the kings of comedy day
like chill out with the loud suit and
take off some of the jewelry
because you're eloquent you're
articulate
you're actually playing something but if
you have a
big ring on and big earrings and you're
wearing a chain
um then it can be quite distracting
i remember that day i i changed the way
that
i looked because i did want people to
pay attention to what i was saying ah
you know and it's it's it's interesting
i didn't have that you know when i got
started with
you know chains or the way i looked you
know it was
the jokes that i constantly did on
sportscenter
it was a 100 non-stop joke fest for me i
mean i was a stand-up comic in college
nate
and and so i had to i had to pull back
in terms of everything being a gag
like i had to pull back on that so what
i was saying would get through and that
is that is
that is a key to you know getting to
where you want to get in this business
and now
you know do you feel like do you feel
like after
kind of earning your spot and then
earning the respect and then really
solidifying yourself as one of the
biggest voices in all the sports
do you feel like you could tap back into
that later because i do feel like now
i can tap back into those spaces where
yes i want to dress
a little bit more fashionably or even
wear my hair a little bit more stylish
i can embrace certain things that maybe
i couldn't do early on
damn straight absolutely nobody's
telling me you joke too much now i mean
it it it and you've established yourself
and
you know and now it's it's terrific i i
do look forward to seeing what you do
next and what you want to do and you
know and in terms of you know
being able to give you advice on on all
of that you tell me i've never won
so you tell me
you know so you you'll have to inform me
okay i've never
they're trying to ask you out like they
did leonardo dicaprio man
you know yeah we gotta we gotta get to
it here's the thing
i would have assumed before this
conversation
yes that you got you got five of those
things no
no very much not so basically you're
telling me i've gotta
start working with scorsese i don't know
if he's gonna do anything with nfl
network
you gotta wrestle the bear like leo did
dude
that's well in the meantime i've just
got the chicago bears to just lean back
over here we go
there you go see that's why you deserved
nate burleson here on the the rich eisen
show okay
so what do you think is going on in
in green bay what's what what they're
thinking in that locker room
right now nate what do you think's
happening there
i originally said this is much to do
about nothing i said you know what
aaron rodgers is going to be there as
soon as the season ends he's a little
frustrated
but he's going to come to his senses
he's going to show up because he knows
that
being there for his teammates is much
more important than
this little rift that he might have with
the front office now as the weeks go on
um and i see aaron rodgers
not talking in the media he's not
responding to everything that the fans
are saying
and the team is moving on without him
right now
i do believe that uh my my
tune has changed on it a little bit um i
still feel like
aaron rodgers doesn't have too many
options i think the best place we're all
thinking right is denver
because they have a good young nucleus
of wide receivers
courtland sutton is going to be back you
have some beast that running back
and that defense it should be as strong
as it used to be so okay so if that's
the case
then aaron rodgers could end up there
but if that isn't a deal that's going
down
name another place every other place
pretty much solidified with their
quarterback
now would a team shift their their
quarterback room to
invite aaron rodgers this in for sure
no doubt about it but i i don't think
that aaron rodgers
at the at the end of him sitting down
with himself
looking in a mirror reflection then
asking
do i want to go somewhere else and
re-establish myself
as the best quarterback and one of the
best to ever play the game
i know we all couldn't imagine tom brady
playing somewhere else and he went to
tampa
and and pulled what i think is the
greatest move in all of sports
at his age leaving a place like new
england and winning in tampa of all
places
i'm not sure aaron rodgers is thinking
to himself i could do the same thing
even though he is younger faster
maybe a bigger arm than tom brady at
this point in his career
it's just i feel like there's a little
bit of luck involved
and everything has to go right just like
it did for tom brady now to answer your
question about
what guys are thinking in the locker
room i remember devonte adams initially
came out this was months ago and he said
well you know if aaron rodgers doesn't
come back i'm going to have to seriously
consider things around here
and it was it was a little bit of a
broad statement
but once you actually show up and then
you start thinking about your own
pockets
that's when reality sets in i know that
the team is sitting back saying
hey ross show up what are you doing we
all love you
we praise you you're one of the top paid
quarterbacks in the nfl
you're paid to deal with the bs you're
paid to deal with the frustration
you're paid to to make sure that the
rest of the locker room is all
on board and i said that on the show so
i'm not sitting there
as a former player acting like i've
never been in position and
i'm sticking my nose and aaron rodgers
business and rodney knows i love him
i say it all the time i wish i played
with him and he lit
my teams up i saw a greatness firsthand
when he was out there
one of the smoothest quarterbacks the
effortless effortlessly effortlessly
pick apart my defense but when it comes
to
him playing right now and the amount of
money he has
i feel like he just has to get out his
feelings
and get his butt into the facility have
a face to face with everybody in the
organization say
give me more control of some of these
decisions because
year in and year out you guys aren't
making the right one
and i think he touched on something nate
where nate burleson here on the rich
eisen show it's just that
you know what what is the alternative
like if he does say he
doesn't want to go back there again
where where would he go
you know and and it's got to be in the
afc even he has to understand it's going
to have to be in the afc
even if he does push it although we did
have rob demosky who covers the team for
espn on the show yesterday he's like
there's no chance the packers trade him
this year
because the draft choices that they
would get for him this year
rogers would improve by performing well
there
as opposed to doing it next year when
the teams that would get him
would have a draft position much worse
because rogers wasn't there it's kind of
an interesting
take as to why the packers would never
trade him but let's just wave a wand and
say
that it would somehow happen there's no
way denver
is better than green bay to win this
coming year even with rogers going there
in a new place that he would have to
learn and figure things out and get
comfortable in right i mean it's just
that's what's so
rare about brady is that he just showed
up and it happened i mean that's another
reason why
he's maybe driven nuts because it worked
out so well for brady but i don't know
how repeatable that is
nate yeah and even if you're if people
are listening and saying
all right all right but what about what
about peyton manning what about peyton
manning remember when he landed in
denver
yeah but he had that one year where he
broke the record he was unbelievable
right
and then that following year peyton
manning didn't necessarily
carry his team to a super bowl that was
that defense ron miller
that defense was fantastic in fact
peyton manning
you started to see that age really
reveal itself
later in the year i believe osweiler
took some slap snaps yes
so so for me i i i just feel like the
best case scenario
is for him to stay exactly where he is i
mean devonta
had 18 touchdowns last year you want to
go somewhere else and establish
chemistry with a
another wide receiver that that doesn't
know how you like to throw the boss
right out the break when your receivers
are running the slant or they they can't
anticipate
that out route because they don't know
the rhythm of how you toss the rock
around
like i just don't think that's the case
and then you know i mentioned denver
you're also going to a division
where a living monster is i mean this
dude
is the boogeyman with the smile on his
face
patrick mahone's is fantastic and if you
don't think
patreon homes after having that
procedure on his toe and getting
whooped in the super bowl and everybody
on his offense
that he leans on including a healthy
clyde edward de lair
you don't think that he's going to come
back and try to light this league on
fire you don't think he's going to come
back and try to get the mvp again
so aaron rodgers is that what you want
you want to play in that division and go
through that gauntlet and that
afc or do you want to stick in the nfc
where you are year in and year out a
contender not for the playoffs but for a
super bowl
nate burleson few more minutes left with
the emmy award winning analyst
right here on the rich eisen show who
are we not talking about because we're
focused on rogers or
we're going to talk about what russell
wilson had to say about never
requesting a trade um and you know
desean watson
before everything that did go down with
him i mean we've been focused on so much
who's
under the radar and giving us an uh are
going to
going to give us a bit of a jolt in 2021
best you can tell here in june
nate i'm hearing some reports about
trevor lawrence in the rhythm that he
has which is why
he was already come on and well i know i
know i know i
i listen i there's something about the
underdog that i
identify with i mean i was playing in
detroit when i was watching calvin
johnson like the league on fire but at
the same time my city was going broke
so i i identify with the teams that
people
aren't talking about okay um you know
now i hear that uh
with the wide receivers they're piecing
together one hell of a group you got dj
shark and leviska channel marvin just
watch out for the jack
like there it's not it's not it's not as
much of a rebuild as people think
another team we're not talking about as
much and i'm really curious to see what
kyle shanahan
is going to do in san francisco because
i really do give them a pass for last
year
they dealt with the most they had the
most guys on ir
and yet and still they were fighting
throughout the season
now you're getting all these guys back
healthy but what's going to happen at
the quarterback position
i'm fascinated by that that that trade
land selection
even though we kind of thought that kyle
shanahan had to
have the gut to do it still
you have jimmy garoppolo getting paid
over 100 million dollars and
took his team to a super bowl and you go
with trey lance
what does that tell you that tells me
that he's ready to move on from jimmy g
but jimmy g didn't get traded which i
thought it would have been a
a great landing spot um in new england
if they would have worked that out
but now they're sitting back in a
division where russell wilson
is verbally trying to prove that that
whole trade fiasco wasn't him
and i think he's also talking to
everybody who thinks that
russell wilson is this stagnant
quarterback that might have plateaued
when he he went to the media yesterday
and said listen i feel younger i feel
better i feel faster i feel stronger i
feel as good as i've ever felt
it's like a a dude that's uh you know
think he's going to lose his wife he's
like hey babe listen
i went and got the the new motorcycle i
leather jacket and i'm taking these
supplements from uh the black market and
you know things are going to be good
baby
we might even uh you know make some kids
this year you know i think that
russell's telling everybody
i get it i get it we're regular season
good and we make the playoffs every year
and we get knocked out but but this year
is different this year's different
i'm feeling a little bit different and i
want to go get a super bowl ring
so that division is really fascinating
to me man i i
didn't forget we haven't talked about
kylie murray in the rams it's just
my guy matt stafford is he is he going
to have a harmonious relationship
with sean mcvay and isn't this the
ultimate test of how genius john mcveigh
really is
right because we were talking about him
when he first got in the league and it's
like all right
yo you got a true gunslinger sometimes
going to old school
griffin and rip it quarterback matt
stafford is going to let that thing fly
so the pressure isn't on staff with all
the wide receivers it's not sean mcvay
in the game plan
so the nfc west just like last year
i think could be the most fascinating
division and then you've got the browns
that i don't think people are kind of
paying attention to
three third place schedule 11 wins they
got their they got a playoff win under
their belt they gave a scare
to the eventual afc champs and odell's
coming back
i mean that one about that you know that
one's under the radar and then
and then you know uh last one too is is
maybe the
defending champs you know what i mean
like i know brady came out and said this
is
this is different everyone this is it's
not the same because he's basically
giving everyone a message like
let's not just think we're going to run
it back because we got everyone back
i mean and and and and then there's the
opportunity that things can change if
you get the right guy too
as we saw uh you know because we were
there we were
we were there when i was calling watson
winston and winston watson
in the booth that day uh nate um and
and we were there that day and the that
if i had told you well we'll put it up
on the screen right here of me and you
uh
having some fun before the game but if
if somebody came up to say by the way
this is where the super bowl is going to
be next year and uh the
brady and the buccaneers are going to
win it where would you like what
you know what i mean like it's amazing
how things can turn in the list
and if my memory served me serves me
correctly famous winston started that
game off with an interception i
believe it was a pick six and then he
ended it with the interception
so the taste in the mouths of these
buccaneers fans was just
raw and they're like ah we can't do this
again and we kind of knew the writing
was on the wall for jameis
but then tom comes in and just has one
of the greatest what could have been
walk-offs of his career and and right
off into the sunset the fact that he's
not retiring
tells me one or two things um one that
he's addicted to the game
and you know i know the word addiction
has a negative connotation but he's
addicted to success and that's okay
and then two i don't feel like they have
a chance of running it back like they
brought back everybody
they're re-upping guys i don't know
where they're getting this money from
the coaches are getting extensions
um but that does lead me to one last
thing before we go i love talking
football with you rich um
jameis winston and taysom hill sean
payton this is your life
drew brees is no longer a saint the
roster is still solid
i was in new orleans uh this past
weekend with the wife and
and these fans like they are ready
to win this isn't oh let's let's hope
james can be a bridge quarterback or
something they want to win now
and i do feel like because jameis
winston will let that thing go too
let's not forget joke about the 30 for
30 30 td 30 sessions you all should do
for 5 000 yards he's dead
you cannot laugh at that so jamie
swinson is gonna have this office a
little bit more explosive
so as as i heard in new orleans this
past weekend with that accent
i'm ready to go baby nate
really appreciate the time congrats
again on the emmy um
and let's chat again uh later on in the
summer before the season i hope to see
you soon
i appreciate it you bet same to you
congrats that's nate burleson everybody
the emmy award-winning
studio analyst of good morning football
and cbs
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here